foreign
[Music]
do something bad
it was like right after the trial for
that too when he came out with that song
yeah I mean but it was so good it was so
good but it was just so wildly toned
deaf no no I mean I get it came out with
an entire album called Chocolate Factory
yeah two two baby
they want ROTC dog bandanas ROTC condoms
uh imagine like you get caught like
[__] having sex with an underage
person and then the next [__] album
it's like [__] God I love young [__]
yeah I mean it's like you know this is a
little tone death he really leaned into
it after marrying a 15 year old Aaliyah
so [__] yeah right that was [__] dude
dude back they were just interviewing
them like you could find old interviews
right remember he was fine with it a 15
year old Aaliyah with a grown-ass R
Kelly and they're like so and nobody was
even don't you think it's a little weird
no it's just like so you guys are
together and it's like no he's 15. she
15 okay
have have y'all heard have y'all heard
the last the last song that R Kelly put
out from jail wait R Kelly put us no no
he didn't put a song
are you being serious
I'm dead ass cause I can't tell because
it could be a skit with this [__]
dead ass this is one of those ones where
I am not [__] with you hold on
at least let me send you this in link
for real
wait but like from like how did he
record it like the record episode like
how they rap and locked up
oh my God he really did okay here we go
all right
first the album's called I admit it
here it is
[Music]
released it literally says released in
prison
[Music]
do we ever get any singing
you could hear the echo you could hear
the echo listen listen listen listen
this is really him this isn't like yeah
no no no no no
hold on everyone everyone shut up and
listen to the echo it sounds like a Jim
Ross voice over
[Music]
it's like when you take a phone call in
the bathroom and no matter how much you
try to hide it someone goes are you in
the bathroom
because as you can see in the [__]
echoing it's really but girl you have
come and made me believe
how did he get a phone in there is he
recording it over the phone like no you
you actually get a lot more [__] in jail
these days dude you get like tablets and
[__] now yeah
[Music]
I just sent you a year
can I say something though really good
I'm not I'm gonna be honest with you now
he's a horrible person he deserves to be
in jail he's a horrible person but
guys still got some pipes can we can we
be honest here oh no listen listen
listen listen listen yeah okay I am 100
in agreement R Kelly might be one of the
worst human beings ever ever ever ever
ever but that man's voice he has the
voice of an Angel he should get up
against the wall after his next like
three person album put out a couple more
put a couple more of an Angel he should
be able to put out music as community
service the next album is going to just
be called commissary yeah it was like an
angel knocking on lot's door
this is a remixing the prison hiding
fresh out the kitchen
I know it's like I I am in prison but
they let me work in the kitchen
laughs
oh
breakups just apparently like he did I
admitted thing and he never admits
anything in the song and they compared
the song to uh OJ's if I did it book
yeah it is basically trade me basically
said oh my God I admitted is three parts
I admitted one two and three I admit it
is three parts
no
[Music]
voice all right try to divorce the fact
that this man pissed on a 15 year old
one second okay hold on this song is a
banger bro okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
ignore I like the theme of the song as
look mistakes were made
look you said some things we all did
some stuff here
[Laughter]
this is
[__] Christ what the [__] man you
made some mistakes
he's mad at them that the people turn
fake there's nothing worse there just
there's nothing worse than people that
are just like fake I know [__] fake
people are the worst
I can't believe this is
admit it was so hard to focus I didn't
go to classes I admit that I dropped out
well you did go to classes to pick up
dates
we know you didn't go to class you can't
read oh no he can't out of school I
admit that I wasn't that cool I admit I
just feel like we're tired well no no
sir what you're doing is not retiring
you're arrested
Bernie Madoff retirement plan admit I
just don't feel like trying but all my
real [__] around me keep telling me
kills [__] that you gotta keep climbing
I
don't [__] with a couple of fans I
thought he's gonna say I made it I did
what I did I [__] a couple of kids I
swear to God it would have rhymed you
could no he didn't know listen to that
story on purpose he did that on purpose
he did that on purpose right hear that
on purpose
it's like a Bo Burnham line where he
ends on the world yes you're right the
wrong one
I admit I'm a gift and a curse I admit
that I don't go to church
[Music]
I'm gonna come I'm gonna get out of here
we're gonna have a comeback
no but you're not you're in jail forever
you're gonna have a [__] Redemption
Arc how long did he get Fergie how long
did he get he got almost pretty much
essentially a life 31 years I think yeah
um
hey mershner pointed out he admitted he
gotta marry a mother-in-law you have to
marry your daughter 20 years you got 20
years all right what out of 15. best
[__] believe that if R Kelly walked
out of jail tomorrow
[__] and put an album out it'd be a
banger promote it and it would sell all
it would fly the [__] off the shelves no
Virgie you gotta you got well it was you
he got 20 years Federal he still has 30
years in the states
yeah he's done
yeah yeah even even if he only serves
half of the state [__] that's still
like 35 years and he's like what like
50. black dudes
huh yeah he's in his 50s he's gonna die
in jail
yeah he should have died already black
dudes die at like 56.
well now he was sucking adrenochrome
straight from the faucet
if you actually uh you know have money
and access to like you know
good doctors and like gyms and stuff I
mean yeah God punished people that die
young are the ones that eat all of their
food off of a smoker
by so many bottles yeah I [__] up this
just because [__] I had a hell of a day
but I admit I was in my own way I admit
I had my mama crying over me what else
can a [__] say I admit I can't spell
for [__] wait
you know
I need that I need that sound drop this
is so good making the typo how is this
real how is this a real thing that's
happening I know I didn't I didn't no
clue that this happened God exists yeah
he's [__] hilarious
[Music]
I admit I couldn't read the teleprompter
the admit I love God but wait it's so
much temptation but wait hahaha
[Music]
what did he just say you heard him no
you heard them no
hahaha
hold on
this is just
let them go just free them but you know
what I'm I agree I agree you know what
let R Kelly Go free free this man
because I can't dispatch has he not
suffered enough we need to get because I
can't stand this jail music we had to
get him back with a real producer okay
this this music's terrible
who's the most famous locked up producer
that can work together I mean look I
understand he did some bad things but
like do we have to suffer no that's you
know what that's a [__] great point
so he rapes children and we get punished
so now he's not gonna get a third remix
to ignition
sorry not fair frankly yeah locked in
the closet part 47 yeah so now now we
have more victims now the kids are
victims and now we're victims we already
had the kids are already victims can we
can we get some more R Kelly please
cheese Mail Right R Kelly must have a d
studio in jail Niles Niles T Studio
oh [__]
speaking of it's so tonight is so
tonight alive is he in jail no uh
oh my god listen to me
we get such night we'll hook them up
right
with R Kelly [__] new album
I just sent you a classic Royce somebody
arrested somebody arrests Timbaland is
he arrested can somebody arrest
Timberland can somebody arrest him but
like can somebody please arrest him
it probably doesn't do anything
oh [__]
oh far I remember this
I didn't have a segue but it's a classic
[Music]
hey there Huey Riley I couldn't help but
notice your sign and I hope you boys
aren't too upset about me having to
prosecute Mr Kelly amen science is free
our color you do what you got to do hi R
Kelly huh what did R Kelly do to you
he's accused of relieving himself on an
underage girl on tape which is against
the law okay okay okay
ballistic Sam in this whole peeing thing
so I can pee in the toilet and it's okay
but if I pee on a person it's like not
okay
foreign
Riley was the best man
Boondocks was the [__] best man